convierte 150 grados y menos 45 grados a
radiantes y bueno vamos a recordar un
poco todo lo que hemos construido
entonces yo lo primero que voy a hacer
es una circunferencia aquí va a ser este
círculo que estoy dibujando aquí va a
ser mi circunferencia porque solamente
es el perímetro de este círculo lo estoy
haciendo lo mejor posible y a mano libre
es un poco difícil hacerlo pero no me
quedo bueno me quedo bien este va a ser
mi radio y si yo recuerdo lo que hemos
aprendido durante toda la vida es que
una circunferencia tiene 360 grados
bueno esto es la cantidad de la medida
angular en grados de una circunferencia
ahora si yo me pregunto cuánto vale el
perímetro de una circunferencia pues yo
recuerdo que para darle toda la vuelta a
mi circunferencia lo que necesitaba era
multiplicar dos veces pi por el radio se
acuerdan la longitud de la
circunferencia
es igual a dos veces pi por el radio o
dicho de otra manera dos radios entonces
lo voy a escribir aquí si yo quisiera
darle toda la vuelta a mi circunferencia
entonces la longitud de este perímetro
es dos ping por el radio o dos y radios
usando la misma idea haciendo análogos
si yo le quiero dar la vuelta completa
al círculo pero esta vez medir el ángulo
en radiales es decir que la medida
angular sean los radiales entonces la
cantidad de raciones que hay en dar una
vuelta entera va a ser de 2 y radiales
recuerden que 2 pirra vianés es una
medida angular mientras que 2 por el
radio o dos radios es una medida de
longitud y bueno con esto construyamos
la siguiente igualdad dos privaciones es
lo mismo que 360 grados y yo ponía
grados para no confundirme entre las
unidades angulares y después decía si
dos pirra tienes es igual a 360 grados
entonces si yo divido esta igualdad en 3
de ambos lados de la igualdad me va a
quedar 2 pie entre 2 bryant es 360 entre
2 y 2 pie entre 2 espira dianes y del
otro lado me queda 360 entre 2 que son
180 grados y me quedaba mi segunda
igualdad que era pirra vianés es igual a
180 grados la cual era bastante útil
para hacer mis transformaciones de
radiales a grados y de grados a radiales
irradian es es igual a 180 grados ahora
qué es lo que pasa si yo necesito
convertir 150 grados para empezar a
radiales bueno lo que hacía era dividir
esta igualdad de ambos lados entre 180
grados o entre radiales para que me dé 1
primero vamos a dividirlo entre 180
grados entonces pi radian es entre 180
grados entre 180 grados es lo mismo que
uno porque 180 grados entre 180 grados
es lo mismo que uno esto me va a servir
bastante para hacer mis conversiones o
dicho otra manera
si yo lo que quiero hacer es dividir
todo entre pi radiales me quedaría que
uno éste mismo uno va a ser igual a 180
grados entre
vamos a ponerlo aquí este uno que por
cierto es igual a pie radiales entre 180
grados va a ser también igual a 180
grados entre y radiales y es que este
uno es un uno especial porque este uno
me ayuda a cancelar las unidades que yo
tengo para poder convertir tanto de
grados a radiales como de radiales
sagrados de hecho ahorita quiero
convertir de grados a radiales así que
vamos a hacer el ejercicio ya con estos
dos unos unos especiales que yo tengo
aquí entonces quiero convertir 150
grados a radiantes 150 grados y lo voy a
pasar a radiales ahora lo importante de
este ejercicio viene justo aquí como lo
que quiero es pasarlo a radiales
entonces los grados me tienen que quedar
abajo y esto es porque lo que quiero
hacer es que los grados que tengo
originalmente se cancelen con los grados
que están dividiendo y mi resultado me
quedé en radiales este es el consejo que
te doy y es muy importante y si tú
entiendes bien este consejo ya la vida
va a ser bien fácil para ti fíjate bien
aquí tengo pi radian es es igual a 180
grados es este uno especial que tengo
aquí
irradian es igual a 180 grados que por
cierto esto es igual a 1 y si yo
multiplico por 1 pues no estoy haciendo
nada se dan cuenta realmente multiplicar
por 1 no estoy haciendo nada pero como
este es un uno especial puedo cancelar
dos grados con los grados y ahora sí
tendría 150 pi entre 180 radiales 150
por tim es 150 mm entre 180 radiales 150
de de la pregunta que tenían y de los
radiales y abajo tengo 180 de los grados
y todo esto ya está dado en radiales
porque son las unidades que me quedaron
150 pi entre 180 radiales ahora 150 en
380 se puede simplificar el 0 y el 0 se
van y me queda 15 entre 18 lo cual tiene
3a y me quedan 5 y abajo
5 sextos lo divide todo entre 30 y entre
30 por lo tanto mi resultado van a ser 5
y sextos radiales o 5 sextos de pi
radiales ya ha simplificado ya súper de
lujo ya genial ahora lo que voy a hacer
es fijarme en mi segunda pregunta que es
convierte en menos 45° arrayanes y bueno
recuerda que el signo menos no nos
tienen que espantar demasiado menos 45
grados no quiero pasar a radiales y como
es lo mismo tengo que pasar de grados
arrayanes voy a utilizar la misma
fracción es decir irradian es entre 180
grados y me fijo que los grados estén
dividiendo para que se puedan cancelar
grado y grado se van y me van a quedar
menos 45 entre 180 radiales entonces
vamos a escribirlo me queda menos 45 y
con color amarillo pin entre 180 verdes
entre 180 y con amarillo radiales que
son las unidades angulares que estoy
convirtiendo perfecto y después me doy
cuenta que 45 y 180 se pueden
simplificar 45 cabe cuatro veces exactas
en 180 por lo tanto si yo simplificó
esto me va a quedar uno arriba y cuatro
abajo es decir menos un cuarto de piedra
de danés o menos pi cuartos radiales
entonces este es uno éste es cuatro
estoy dividiendo todo entre 45 y me
queda al final menos un cuarto de piedra
de danés o menos para cuartos radiales
es más vamos a escribirlo esto es igual
a menos no olvidemos el menos pi cuarto
radiales y que buen trabajo porque ya
hemos acabado